all right so we'll get started
so um i have something good
uh to make your lunch uh
very uh pleasant i think so we are going
to talk about
building a microservices architecture
based on asp.net core so i'm going to
make sure that i uh finish this
presentation in time so we'll have about
60 minutes to talk about how to do a
microservices setup based on network on
asp.net core my name is joe i'm from
belgium i lead experience which is a
high level consultancy company so we do
this stuff all the time on
making sure that companies set up
architectures for their mooc for their
mobile applications for their web
applications uh in a correct way um i'm
also a pluralsight author
i've been doing this for uh close to 10
years and this is actually a bit of a
synopsis really of a very large course
that i have on microservices
architecture on pluralsight so if this
is to your liking well then you can go
out to pluralsight and uh listen to me
for about five hours also maybe good for
lunch or to fall asleep i don't know um
and then i will dive a lot deeper into
setting up this microservices
communication based on asp.net core if
you don't have access to pluralsight uh
come up to me after the session i'll
write down your email and then i can
give you a month of free access to to
access whatever course you want
all right so since we don't have too
much time let's dive straight in
i'm going to
do this using a business case we're
going to look at a company effective
company called global ticket
which is in need maybe maybe of moving
to a microservices setup so that's what
we're going to be using um first i'm
going to show you a symbol single
microservice which is actually just an
api and then we're going to start
bringing in multiple microservices and
how they are going to communicate how
they're going to relate with one another
is is what we're going to look at next
so the microservices architecture and
the microsoft's communication part and
if we have time well we should have in
fact also look at how we can connect
with these microservices there are
multiple ways of having a front-end or
multiple front-ends connect with that
microservices setup so that's what i'm
going to
be explaining to you in the next 60
minutes
so as mentioned we're going to use a
effective company called global tickets
and global ticket is maybe in need of a
micro services setup let's see what they
are doing so as the name is already
giving away so global ticket is a a
ticket seller or ticket vendor a
reseller company so they sell tickets
for all kinds of uh of concerts and
conferences like these and so they're
really a market leader in the ticket
selling business so they're very global
company and they have
a system of selling tickets of course
um and in there in this fictive
application that we're going to be using
um the users of the application so it's
really the end user application that
we'll be looking at people can do all
kinds of well regular things that you
can do with a ticket shop you can browse
the catalog you can put tickets in your
shopping basket
maybe you have a discount code so we
need to apply that one as well and then
of course you can uh create the order
and then you actually also have to make
a payment and maybe there's also some
marketing information that we need to
capture based on what tickets people
have in their baskets we may also want
to give them recommendations on other
related sorts of concerts or events in
general so these are the features of the
application that we'll be looking at so
instead of talking about it i'm going to
give you a quick demo so the actual
application is not really what matters
in this presentation it's of course more
the code and how to set up the
architecture but it does give you a bit
of a a better understanding of the
application that we are talking about
i'm going to start it here you're going
to see a lot of
apis booting up hopefully
there we go
just a second here i should have booted
this up already but it actually
shouldn't take very long
there we go
yeah i make it a bit larger even yeah i
didn't have the time to actually
test it is this readable for everyone
yeah
i can't see you because of the light in
my face yeah there we go i see some
hands going up
all right so this is global tickets
as mentioned it's a global it's a ticket
selling website where i can
select this ticket see the details
select the number of tickets i want to
add to my basket
this is the shopping cart page or which
i can update i can apply a discount code
and if i'm good then i click here on
checkout now
this will create oh this will take me to
the order page which i need to fill in
quickly because there's some simple
validation on there let's take this
effective email
there we go
and then we'll place the order
and this will send that off
there's an asynchronous process we'll
talk about that that is happening right
now which is hopefully uh accepting my
payment and if we're good it can take a
while so i'm not sure if it's
already going to be there then at some
point the order will show up here has
maybe gone through with the payment or
not so that's basically the application
that will use for this uh presentation
nothing more nothing nothing very
special it's just a front end sitting on
top of the microservices that we'll take
a look at
so now that you know what we're going to
be building let's take a look at the
current state at deliver tickets
the global ticket has been building this
application for a long time and it's
been built as a typical monolith
now to be to be clear there's nothing
wrong with a monolithic application
don't rush out here and and go tell your
boss or your cto whatever we need to
change everything into a microservices
setup that is not the case i'll talk
about why it can be useful but keep that
in mind having a monolithic application
there's really nothing wrong with this
because there's definitely some
advantages to having a monolithic
application it's easy to deploy it's
easy to bring new members on the team
because its setup is probably easy to
understand as well and it probably is
also easy to test because that is one of
the downsides that we'll see when
building or when going into
microservices setup it might be more
difficult to test so having a monolithic
application which is what global ticket
has at this point absolutely fun so this
could be a very simple setup in which
they have maybe an asp.net core
razer pages or mvc application in which
they have one overarching application
but that does pretty much everything it
goes from the uh it does it handles the
event catalog which has some controllers
some views maybe that's an area in an
mvc application then they have the
shopping basket and they have the
discount functionality that handles that
that discount code that you could enter
in the shopping basket as well so really
one application that does it all
but
being a ticket selling website well they
are facing a couple of problems and i
have listed a few of them here well the
current application is a three-tier
traditional setup nothing wrong with
that we already mentioned that but it
does have
being a ticket a ticket selling website
some issues maybe here and there when
when a conference like this one goes
online there's a very high peak in
demand because of everyone willing to be
here and
and that results in a slow response time
and a slow website in general everyone
is on twitter these days so as soon as
the site goes down these ctos on the ceo
starts seeing it on the on twitter again
oh global ticket is slow again he
doesn't want that anymore that's
definitely one of the issues that we can
encounter with such such a setup
another issue that
that based on the current setup might be
difficult to address is also the fact
that they cannot handle multiple
frontends because they've built
everything as a monolithic application
maybe with an asp.net core application
they don't have an easy way to allow for
maybe a third-party api to come in or a
mobile application to connect those
things can actually be pretty hard to
put into an existing setup in which
everything was done in one go another
thing is also that
as the teams grow maybe multiple teams
will start building different parts of
the application and maybe they are
interested in using a different tech
stack maybe the the departure that just
uh mentioned about the marketing part
maybe they're building some ai in there
and they want to use python to see based
on the consumer
history of purchases what might be the
next thing they want to do and they
might want to do that on a different
stack and that might also be hard to fit
into a monolithic application and maybe
those people also want to release more
often than the general application
because if you have a monolithic
application in general it will be uh
released in one go it's all or nothing
really so those are maybe some issues
that we might be facing when building a
monolithic application and maybe just
maybe a microservices setup
could introduce us to a solution here
when we are going to introduce
microservices at global tickets we're
basically going to be well splitting up
the application in multiple smaller
applications smaller islands of
functionality that's what i like to call
them smaller services which are really
standalone functionality standalone
applications they can do everything
themselves they can do they have their
own database they have their own model
we'll talk about that in just a second
they really are islands of functionality
that do one thing one task maybe they do
the discounts maybe the shopping basket
will talk about the different
microservices that you need but that's
what they'll do they'll do just one
thing they have their own data
maybe they're owned by one team again
think back of what i just said maybe
that team that wants to build the market
marketing service has that functionality
in hand they have the knowledge they
want to release that well maybe that
service that application is owned by one
team and it can also easily evolve over
time
not thinking about machine learning
stuff but maybe we're building with net
core and we have a dependency on one
typical one particular version of net
core which is blocking the entire
application from moving to net six well
if we split it up with multiple
microservices while we can maybe just
have one single microservice that needs
to stay on an older version but all the
other services can already evolve into
the next version and that may arrive
with something like this high level
we're going to have a front-end
application
we'll talk about those by the end of the
presentation that talk with different
standalone applications and those will
be the microservices and those will in
fact just be apis as well
um why they can be a solution well there
are different reasons and i already
mentioned quite a few but
like i said they can be and notice the
quotes around the can because that is
very important it's not the solution for
every problem that you may encounter
it can actually make
the creation of larger applications
because microservices are typically used
for larger systems it can make the
creation of those a bit simpler they'll
also
think back of what i said earlier one of
the problems that global ticket was
facing was the availability maybe when
the entire application is just a
monolithic application it can be hard to
actually have it be available all the
time since there are separate uh since
it's just one service that handles
everything if you have micro services we
can more easily tweak and find you then
we can improve the scalability because
of the different microservices being in
place and like i already mentioned
it is possible to have different
services do or use different
technologies one can use a machine
learning
setup using python another one can use
an old version of net and another one
can use dot net 6. so you can have
different
services use different technologies
now it is not all
good in the length of microservices and
now i'm maybe painting a picture that is
very positive but it's definitely not
always going to be the solution as i
already mentioned it
the first thing that is pretty hard to
do is finding the different
microservices it's not a very clear cut
all the time
this is a damage setup and of course
it's going to be easy to see well that's
a microservice and that's a microservice
and that's another one that works in a
in a demo but it might not always be the
case with your own business domain so
finding what should be a microservice is
sometimes hard to do i already mentioned
the fact that it's more difficult to
test very often you're working by
default in a distributed system and
distributed systems are hard to test
they're definitely much that more
difficult to test than having a simple
asp.net core application that has
everything in one place i know it's
going to be other technical
challenges that you encounter think of
the fact that you have different
services communicating with one another
if one goes down well what happens with
the rest of the system you'll need to
think of things like resiliency how am i
going to retry maybe communicating
between a service that that is down or
something and and how i'm going to retry
that communication
and maybe also
thinking already about the front end
maybe they need different bits of data
so that's also an issue that we're going
to try to solve in this presentation and
in general the communication between
different services is hard
instead of having just a few classes
that need to talk to one another now you
are responsible for having multiple
applications communicate with one
another so communication between these
services is definitely one of the
challenges that you come across
so now that we have set the groundwork i
think for having possibly a solution
with microservices at global ticket
let's see how we can actually build that
and we'll start with the first one a
simple
single microservice and then we'll start
adding the other ones we'll have them
communicate and we'll bring in front end
so a first microservice
and now before i show you those
microservices and and the in the first
one that we'll start with uh let me
quickly recap what the application was
supposed to do as these are the
requirements to pick a list of
requirements what are we going to be
have what are we going to do with the
application we're going to browse the
catalog
we're going to be able to add items to
the shopping cart and we've seen that
then we can create the order we can
maybe while doing so apply a discount
code then we can process the payment
that you didn't see because that happens
in the background to talk about that and
um i missed one i think i can also
recommend other events so if you get
this list of requirements in in real
life it's not often that clear but i
think it's pretty easy to see what are
going to be my different microservices
i'm going to have a service that handles
everything around the catalog um in this
particular case that is going to say
feed the data that is uh that is that
allows me to browse through the
different categories i haven't show you
categories but they are available in
categories those tickets um
but it could also be um
this service let's say could also
possibly handle the admin side of things
maybe creating new types of tickets or
maybe uh doing a group booking or
something so there could also be an
administration site so everything that
evolves let's say around ticket uh event
sorry the catalog of tickets let's say
that is definitely something that is a
step the standalone functionality that
is a first microservice that we've
identified the shopping basket
definitely another one keeping track of
who has what in their basket is
something that is a standalone
functionality we'll see the code of the
microservice or the shopping basket
microservice in a minute because it's a
very important one it's a crucial one
the shopping basket will be the
standalone application that keeps track
of who has what type of tickets which
want it is and so on in the baskets it
will also do stuff with the shop with a
discount code and that is definitely
another microservice that we've
identified there's going to be another
service that is maybe checking the
discount code against the database is
that code already used is it still valid
and so on and so forth that is
definitely also a standalone
functionality that you can wrap inside
of a microservice
there's two more
the order microservice will look at that
one as well that's a very central one in
the setup of services that i'll have
it'll handle ordering so it basically
will go from uh the items in the
shopping basket and move those into the
database of the orders because that is a
different database it's a different data
store that it then handled and is fully
controlled let's say by the order
microservice
payment um we're going to use a
third-party payment system like stripe
or something but we're not using that
directly from within the application i'm
going to add what i what i typically
tend to refer to as a technical
microservice a service that sits in
front of it let's say a layer that sits
in front of your payment system your
external payment system that handles all
the technical details around talking
with that external payment system that's
another microservice that we'll have and
then marketing
at another one that is one that is
responsible for looking at what people
have in the basket and make
recommendations as the ones that are
referred to as maybe something that you
would do with the machine learning
solution all right let's take a look at
all these microservices let's start with
one let's create oh let's look at the
first microservice i don't have time to
do all this by hand and well these
services themselves you don't need to
spend a lot of time at that because that
is just an api a plain asp.net core api
which has and that's important its own
database its own data model its own
controls its standalone it's a
standalone application really so it's
really something that is standing on its
own
so let's take a look at the first
microservice already here
if my mouse wants to work along there we
go
so
without going in too much detail here
already let's collapse everything and
then we'll zoom in
so if you take a look here um we have
different services we have and in the
solution you have different services
each of these i've just explained
already briefly and let's take a look at
the event catalog for example first
catalog is a plain api it's an asp.net
api um and it has its own data structure
so it has defined its own model it has
defined its own uh database context so
that means that it also has its own
database it's a standalone application
really it's an api that does everything
around the event catalog and it also has
of course its own controllers let's take
a look at the event controller for
example here
so the event controller is a send an api
that is accessible via api slash events
a plain event controller which uses some
dependency injection and then has this
uh method here to get all the events as
you can see here and also get an event
by id really nothing special apart from
the fact that i want to point your
attention to the fact that this is using
its own repository which uses the
database context of this system and also
has its own database and in fact all the
other microservices from
a high level perspective are doing
exactly the same
we're not here to talk about these
individual services because those you
can build using something like clean
architecture for example that's not
really the point here this is just a
standalone application on its own
that's the first api that's the first
microservice that we have identified now
we start we need to start looking at how
these different services are actually
going to work together because we're
having a single api well that's not what
we're here for i think we already know
how to build this
so
what is more important of course is how
to make these different services work
together and that's where the
architectural part comes in well this is
this this picture this slide here should
give you a bit of an overview of how
these different microservices will
interact with one another you have again
these different services that i already
mentioned so the event catalog shopping
basket discount marketing payment and
order um and so how is the system of
microservices going to interact with one
another and the thing in the middle is a
mailbox a bus a message bus we'll talk
about that in in just a bit but let's
first see how the
different services can in fact
communicate with one another
you see that i i draw i've drawn this
first arrow here that goes from the
event catalog to the shopping basket
well it's very important to understand
what is happening here there is a front
end we'll look at the front end by the
end of the presentation that actually is
allowing the user to browse the event
catalog that is using the event catalog
service and at some point i'm going to
click on a certain ticket to put that or
to add that to my basket and at that
point the front end is going to say well
in the event in the shopping basket that
user has now added this amount of this
ticket that's what is happening here so
the arrow might be a bit confusing but
that's in fact what is happening
and then the different other services
will also start communicating within uh
with one another the shopping basket
will make
a call to the discount microservice when
i add a discount and i haven't shown you
that i forgot that um when i click on
add discount or buy discount it will
talk with the discount microservice
very similarly
there's going to be communication
between the shopping basket and all the
microservice when i click on
checkout at that point it's going to
wrap all the information and throw it
over the wall towards the the order
microservice the order microservices
stores all the information about the
order and that will then handle or that
will then communicate let's say with the
payment microservice as you see here
that's the error happening here and that
in turn is talking with an external
payment provider and that returns then
information about how that order went
through
and does the error pointing in this way
and then there's also some communication
between uh the
event catalog sorry the shopping basket
and the marketing services these are the
different streams let's say of
information that i have happening
between my different
microservices now i talked about
errors these errors what are they well
they're network calls
normally when we would have classes and
services doing this we would have just
method calls in this case the service
costs their network calls the one
service the one api will talk with
another api yeah um what you will see
and that's the way i and that's also the
way that microservers are typically set
up you have smart endpoints so apis know
what to do and they will communicate
overall basic
types of communication layers so a rest
call or a message buzz and that so and
so on and so forth so we'll talk about
that in just a minute that's the
communication part but the logic will
live inside of the services those are
application endpoints that will uh well
we'll talk with network calls are normal
yeah we have different network calls
going back and forth between those
different systems that is of course
between microservices the way to do it
now don't over don't go overboard with
that
don't make chatty services because going
between services is a network call and
that has a delay right so you have to
keep you have to make your services as
smart as possible but also don't give
them too much information about out of
microservices and that's of course also
sometimes difficult to do and that's
also where you sometimes see that you
have made a decision that you have to
come back to afterwards because you
haven't made the cut between different
microsources correctly but it is as a
normal thing that services will call
other services
so let's take a look at that i'm going
to show you at this point
um
let's take a look at the shopping basket
again the shopping basket if i zoom in
here you'll see that it's very similar
as again a repository has models has a
database context i'm not going to show
you that it's exactly the same structure
at this point but if we if we look at
the controllers let's take a look at the
shopping basket basket controller that's
the main entry point for working with
baskets
when i click on the checkout button in
the ui the ui was actually going to
invoke this method this checkout basket
async method that is getting in a basket
checkout
entity i should say model because it's
not really an entity and if you look at
that one what does it have well it has
information about the basket the basket
id to be precise the basket id is the id
of the basket inside of the database of
the basket service
that is being kept around by the front
end
and the front that is just saying okay
this item goes in the basket this item
goes in the basket it doesn't do that it
just asks the micro service to the the
shopping market microservice to distort
all that information in its database and
at this point
when we click on checkout basket the
service of the shopping basket knows hey
this shopping market is being checked
out i have all that information in my
database so i can handle that perfectly
what is coming in though is all the
information about the user that the user
has entered on the
order screen and at this point that
information comes in as you can see here
there is no information about which
products i'm checking out because i
already have that inside of my shopping
basket that is a very important thing to
remember here
so what will happen based on that basket
id on line 92 i will actually get uh the
information or get the products or the
tickets which are currently inside of
the basket um and then i will actually
start the checkout process right the the
all the creation process i should say
and that's what i'm doing here i'm going
to create a new type a bask checkout
message and i'm going to start filling
that with all the information i have i
have the information of that was entered
by the user on one hand and i also need
information about the basket and that i
get from a local database that was part
of the shopping basket database that is
what we see here
so i'm going to create then the shopping
basket and then maybe the user has also
entered a coupon
a coupon code right because that coupon
code
if you look here it is also coming along
with the basket
with the basket that was entered
now the basket doesn't know about the
coupon codes because that is we've
already seen a different microservice
that handles that at this point we are
already basically creating or preparing
the order but we need to do something
with the coupon code so we need to go
and invoke another service
that's what uh what we'll look at in the
next part because now we'll need to have
multiple microservices communicate with
one another
communication between different
microservices is one of the most crucial
parts in the setup
not only do you need to understand where
a microsoft ends and another one begins
you also need to understand what the
technologies and the the ways of doing
that communication are there are of
course different ways of doing that and
the one is of course better than the
other and i explain both of you
um we can do synchronous communication
synchronous communication is based on a
rest call a grpc call maybe a signal
call
and it is called synchronous not because
it's not using a weight async but it's
synchronous because it's going to be
let's say blocking one microservice
calls another one and the other one is
just waiting to give back so the first
one is waiting for the second one to
give a response so they are in fact
blocking one another that's why i talk
about synchronous microservice
communication i'll talk about that one
first i will soon see that it's not the
ideal solution for many of the problems
a better solution is probably
asynchronous communication why will use
bus based communication or broker-based
communication between the different uh
microservices but let's first look at
synchronous communication between our
different services i have drawn here the
disk microservice that's the one that
will uh will useful for this part of the
application um where in fact another
service is going to come in and ask
discount microservice hey can i get
information about this coupon because i
need to handle that before i can handle
my shopping basket in other words one
api is going to talk in a synchronous
way with another api that's what we'll
have here so we'll have this different
microservices directly invoking another
api another microservice and as
mentioned that is what we have between
the shopping basket and the discount
microservice the discount microservice
keeps track of all the discount codes
right it is still applicable we are
still valid and so on and so forth and
it is invoked by another microservice
and that is the shopping basket
microservice and for their communication
they are using a plate http cost of
arrest-based call rest call that is
sitting between them
let's look at that
um
so i have here
um the discount uh so this line here uh
so line 120. uh on this line i'm going
to basically go out to another service
in the shopping basket service i need to
invoke the
discount microservice now i'm using here
this getcoupon method this getcoupon
method uses
itself a class that is still part of the
shopping basket microservice and that
will invoke using http client the other
microservice the discount microservice
as you can see here i'm invoking api
slash discount and i'm passing in the
coupon code and that is a synchronous
call in the sense that the other so the
shopping basket service needs to wait
for this response to come back right
that is synchronous communication and
while that works if all is is happy and
and there is no interruptions in network
and there's no delays and so on and so
forth this will work fine right nothing
if nothing goes wrong well then this
would work absolutely fine but like i
already said
it could be that um there's a lot of
people ordering tickets for a certain
concert or a certain conference
and then what
it could be that well we're not in an
ideal situation here it could be that we
end up with an with a problem on one end
it could be that
that we have heavy load
that we are in fact
hammering the discount microservice
and it could in fact cause the entire
system to go down the drain
with synchronous communication i've
listed out a few of the possible issues
that we are that we could possibly
encounter here it could be that it
becomes a bottleneck what i was just
saying
if that one microservice is being used
for multiple places in the system and
that all those other places are really
hammering that service it could in fact
bring down that
that poor discount service and then
that could compromise the entire system
not a situation you want to be
because it is difficult to find those
types of errors it could be that
there are intermittent errors with the
discount microservice it might go down
for a certain time and the other
services are timing out and maybe
they're trying again and at some point
the discount microservice might be back
up and then you don't see the address
anymore then you start you need to go
into logs and that sort of thing could
be harder to find what is actually wrong
another issue that i tend to see is
the tight coupling between the different
microservices it might be so that i have
my different services and they're really
they really know a lot about each other
at this what we just saw at this point
that the shopping basket service
actually knows quite a bit about the um
about the discount service it needs to
know well i need to call it with this
parameter and so on and so forth that
may be not an ideal situation in what
we're after and that's actually a
loosely coupled system between different
services that communicate with one
another
like i've already mentioned it is very
easy to
compromise this sort of setup
if you think about
this you could easily have a chain of
different micro services calling one
another because service a or service one
could cause two could cause service
three and so on forth and not
available something goes wrong database
goes out i don't know what
well at some point the entire system can
actually be infected this way because
other microservices are not reachable
anymore and in fact because this
microservice 3 goes down the other one
microservice one and two will actually
also go down and this could cause really
a domino effect throughout your entire
application your entire system of
microservices can go uh can go down and
it can be harder to recover from these
types of errors that is why in most
cases
you will not use synchronous
communication between different
microsofts and you need to default and
say to asynchronous communication
between them
now like i said right
there are places where you might want to
use it this is uh sort of direct
communication synchronous communication
but in general asynchronous
communication is preferred because if
something goes wrong you will still have
a way to more easily recover let's say
because you have some some some
intermediate let's say that sits in
between and that will help you go
through that difficult period
um it's typically a broker-based system
that we'll need to go into
we'll need to talk or we need to move
into a broker-based system as some some
sort of message bus some sort of broker
that all the different microservices
know about and that will then uh
receive messages and it's a forward
messages for all the other microservices
to read from and then they can get the
information when they are ready to do so
when you order something on amazon you
all you typically don't get the email
like straight away it takes a couple of
minutes uh often that is actually
because that order is being processed
it's put up on some some bus and some
other system some other service is
picking it up from that bus and
depending on how busy it is well there
will be a longer delay because we're
waiting for that message to be handled
and that's exactly what we're going to
try to do here as well
and like i already mentioned
asynchronous communication also uses the
system of smart end points and dump
pipes that's what you want you want just
plain communication going through the
pipes we typically don't add any logic
on those messages inside of the
inside of the broker but you have the
smart endpoints knowing what to do when
a certain type of message comes in
um so this is what you'll get
you have some broker that sits in
between and you have different micro
services of sending messages from one uh
into the broker and then the broker will
then let's say forwards not really
forwarding because they're listening for
messages uh to appear on on that broker
on that bus and that's how the different
services can communicate in a very um
well a very independent way of one
another because it's just the message
that goes through and even if one
microservice needs to change it doesn't
affect the other systems and that's
where that tight coupling comes in again
and that that's what i want to avoid
that is also much easier to avoid uh
doing it this way
now before i show you that um i'm not
going to go too much into this but there
are different ways of doing this sort of
communication between different services
between uh between different services in
general you can do
even though you're thinking well i'm i
should be doing async asynchronous
communication calling service one uh
sorry service one calling service two
you can still do
point-to-point communication it's not
because you have this broker sitting in
between or this q sitting in between
that you cannot do that anymore
absolutely not you can still do what is
known as point-to-point communication so
is one the shopping basket service maybe
directly only talks with the order
microservice absolutely possible it will
send the message into the queue
that queue keeps those messages around
and when that order microservice is
ready it will pick up that message and
it will handle it accordingly
that gives us a much more reliable
system
it's very well possible that we have
multiple services that are interested in
a certain message appearing in the
system it could be that we have the
event catalog microservice event catalog
like i said thus allows us for browsing
all the
tickets in the system but it may also be
the one that handles a price
change of the of a certain ticket maybe
other microservices need to be let's say
alerted about that well then the event
catalog of microsoft can send a message
into the system and there can be
multiple other services which have
registered for that and they can say
well i'm interested in when a price
change uh happens i need to also know
about that and they can uh
let's say subscribe to that
and it's also possible this way to build
a more extensible system if another
microservice pops into the system we're
extending the system when it's also easy
to subscribe that also to receiving that
message
so where are we doing that well i'm
going to show you the code for
communication between the shopping
basket and the order so that's what
we'll look at but this happens in
multiple places in fact everywhere
in my system except from the discount
service communicating with this with the
shopping basket i'm using that sort of
communication
and we have a service bus and message
bus sitting in between it will send a
message to and that will then let's say
be received by another system
i'm typically more a fan of using azure
service bus you can use whatever type of
bus you want to use if you want to use
another broker that's absolutely fine
i'm using azure service bus here as well
uh the only uh the waste of the things i
typically tend to use here um is um
yeah it's of course cloud-based it has a
high reliability but it also has this
this way of doing topics topics allows
me to have multiple subscribers on
certain messages that's a very good
advantage of of this it also has this
system of debt lettering
even if a message cannot be handled or
never appears on another micro series it
will be it will not be discarded
entirely it will be placed on some
different queue and as a dead ladder
that letter queue allows me to read
through some management or a messaging
queue system that you want to
look at failed messages you can look at
the debt letter and it's of course also
highly scalable and that's why we use it
in in our applications very very often
as well
now let's see how we are doing that how
are we doing that asynchronous
communication between these different
systems
now we'll need to look at we need to
look again at the basket controller
so we had seen this to be synchronous
communication now we're over here
as you can see here on this line here
it's pretty hard to scroll here with the
mouse on this uh on the steep desk here
uh over here i have created that balance
checkout message that is the that's a
type that's a class and that's what is
going to be sent over the wire of course
i need to serialize that we'll do that
in just a second but i have created this
this sort of helper
publish publish message
method here on a message bus now what is
message bus of course that is actually
also a helper class that i wrapped my
azure service bus functionality in i'm
not making all my services dependent on
azure service bus i think that would be
a bad idea to do it that way because
then if someone decides well we're not
going to use azure service bus anymore
we're going to use end service bus well
maybe then i have to change all my micro
services i have basically abstracted
that away in this one uh project here
with a separate project that i'm going
to referencing and if i need to change
message
or message systems let's say i can
easily do that
so this publish message here
is what is going to handle
sending a message and i've created for
all my messages a base class integration
base message
and what i'm then doing
is i'm going to create
a topic client topics in service bus
what are basic are let's say separate
buses separate queues that are used to
store certain types of messages and
multiple other subscribers can
can listen to that in fact you're
creating multiple types of topics and
each of those can have multiple
subscribers listen to them you're
basically creating smaller topics
smaller queues within your queue
and what i'm doing here is i'm creating
a client so i'm registering
uh to work with this service business
that i've created here uh in azure
service bus or in azure and what i'm
going to do is i'm going to convert my
message into a string of json and i then
simply sent that message off on the
topic boom for the shopping basket the
the work is over the work is done the
message is waiting on the bus
on the other receiving end so this
message is now in the bus on the other
receiving end we have the order service
and that order service is
if we look at it here it is very well or
it is very interested in receiving those
checkout messages because that's the
time it needs to create an order how
does it know that well maybe we have
maybe we have in here another controller
there's the order controller let's see
what that's what that is doing
no it's not doing anything
and if you think about it
well we're not doing api to api
communication we've put a message on the
bus and this service the
the order service needs to well be
notified about that message coming in
so what i've done instead
is i have created
let's go to the program sorry let's go
to the startup class instead
um over here i have created this azure
service bus consumer class and i've
registered as a singleton within my
application
and at azure service bus consumer
what is that doing
that is going to
over here subscribe
to messages coming in on a certain topic
that's what you see here down here at
the bottom i'm going to subscribe
to a certain message coming in on a
certain topic and when that happens i'm
actually going to invoke code
when a checkout message is received
over here i'm going to register
so when this application starts in fact
i should say i'm going to invoke this
start method using uh
from the startup class i'm going to then
register a message handler that says
that when a checkout message is received
i want to invoke this particular method
here
that method is going to be notified
about the message coming in that was the
basket checkout message placed on the
services by the uh
by the
basket service and this one this service
is responsible for handling or creating
the orders and that's exactly what it's
going to do next so in here in this
let's say background process i'm going
to create an order store it in my
database through the repository and
we're done here in fact we're not done
if you think about the schema again well
the order was actually then going to do
the same thing it was again going to
create a message and it was going to put
another message on the queue on the
azure service bus that is then going to
be an order uh i think an order
repayment request message the first
message that goes into the service bus
again two words and the direction of the
payment gateway and that is what is then
handled here so we send in the
information about the order there we go
that's what we create and then we do the
same thing
messagebus.publishmessage passing in
that order that the payment message
order payment message
that we then have handled by another
service that is also listening for
incoming messages so that's how about
different
microservices are going to communicate
in a very asynchronous way and also in a
very loosely coupled way
if we go back here
there's a couple more things i need to
show you
um
i hope it's clear that the different
microservices
are
not connected to the same database
if you see someone doing microservices
with the same database
they're not doing it right
and i've seen this type of system maybe
we do a microservice we have one
database yeah you're not doing
microservices
this is a very bad way of doing
microservices because then you basically
you just split up your application and
you've probably made it harder on
yourself maybe that's what you want but
job creation that's called um but that's
probably not what you want and you want
to do it you want to do it right and you
probably want to have all of these
microservices have their own database
and they are also not touching each
other's database
you're not going to have one
microservice touching the database
there we go you're not going to have um
one microservice directly doing
something in the database of another
microservice well you could just add the
connection string from one microservice
into the next well again bad thing
bad way of doing things that's not what
you want you want to different
microservices to only communicate using
messages instead of directly changing
something in one artist database so
that's also a way of basically splitting
up
and making sure that these applications
are really standalone and that's what
you want to get to
the final thing that i want to show you
here before we look at the frontends is
something that is known as eventual
consistency
i already mentioned the fact that maybe
some ticket changes its price or the
price is changed to the administration
um pages which i don't have in the
sample but imagine that also being part
of the event catalogue
it could be that um
in a monolithic application when you
change it in the database it's it's
changed for everyone everyone knows
about it right now maybe i'm changing a
price of one of one ticket in one
service and other services also need to
know about that because the order
service keeps track of order sorry the
shopping basket service keeps track of
hey i have five tickets of this type
with this price in my shopping basket so
it needs to know about the price of that
ticket
again
that is not oh again not again that is
something that we need to take into
account and it is known as what is uh
typically known as eventual consistency
it might take
a while
before all the microservices are aware
of a change
and what we need in that case is
typically some sort of different type of
message which is known as an integration
event a fire and forget message
typically
one service will say hey
i have a change in the price
and i'm going to like like i said the
event catalog service might say i have a
price change
i'm going to then publish that into the
system and everyone
who is interested in knowing about that
price change well they need to subscribe
and it is again something that is pretty
easy to do i can very easily create
a service bus in azure and create
multiple topics on that and on those
topics i create multiple subscribers
in fact i can just do it with one topic
excuse me i can do it with one topic and
i have multiple subscribers
registering for what is typically known
as an integration event i fire a message
uh price change into the system and all
the microservices that need to be
notified about that will have registered
for that price change message and they
will automatically oops they will
automatically be
made aware of a price change to the
system and again that is something that
happens through a service bus much more
easily than having direct service
communication
if you want to do this with an api call
imagine that a new service comes in what
that would actually mean that you go
back to all your other services that do
that that publishing of that message
that price change that would make make
it very hard to maintain your system
because you need to keep track of
everything that has changed and all the
new services coming in that would be
really hard this type of communication
makes it a lot easier
and the final thing i want to show you
and because we've now seen the different
microservices how can we now work with
those i've shown you the ui
yeah but how is that ui effect
communicating with these different
microservices well in fact this is what
we've had so far i haven't shown you the
front end the front is a plain asp.net
core nvc application so it has just uh
controllers and in effect has view
services so classes that basically
relieve the controllers from doing too
much but we moved it all into separate
classes but what we that's not really
important for what we're looking at here
what is important is that those or that
mvc application is directly
communicating with the different
microservices direct to microservice
communication is what is being used here
now it works it works absolutely fine
but it doesn't have
uh it doesn't always make up for the
best way of doing your communication
between your front end and your
microservices
because it could be that we have
different microservices communicate
sorry different contents communicating
with those microservices
you're always going to end up with um
coming or information about how the
responses of the different microservices
need to be combined and if an mvc if you
have an mvc application and a
maui application and maybe a third party
api what you're going to end up with is
having to copy that information about
combining the responses multiple times
into each of these frontends typically
not what you want so you will have um
too much information let's say about
your different microservices
inside of the front end and that's not
what you want
you always you're also going to have a
tight coupling and a more
um
hardest time let's say to make your bike
services evolve because if you have your
front end directly talking with your
microservices your microservices change
the api while your front end also needs
to change
we're looking for a a form of less tight
coupling or loose coupling well then
this is often not a good idea
what is often a better idea is well
putting a layer in between and that's
typically known as a gateway the gateway
is basically well let's say an entry
point to the microservices solution or
microservices setup instead of having my
front then directly talk with my
microservices i'm going to have a
gateway an extra layer that sits in
between and that can be shared between
multiple applications so the logic of
combining the answers of microservices
can actually be moved in here
it is typically something that is used
for larger applications but it's
actually something that i tend to do
most of the time and in this case we
often talk about a back-end for
front-end and i'll talk about that in
just a second
before i do that one risk that you have
by creating a gateway is that that
becomes a monolith because it might end
up having too much information about the
different microscopes this is something
to be aware of um and
the the place where you would typically
end up with that is if you have
your gateway has or is the front end for
multiple um
types of application maybe a mobile
application and a web application and so
on it might have too much information
and in that case it's often a better
idea to move to multiple gateways
that's what you see here so this is what
the gateway will do it will basically be
a layer that sits between the front end
and the microservices and it will
communicate with the different services
and only the front-end knows about the
gateway and it knows about it knows
nothing about the individual
microservices it only knows about the
gateway and the gateway will do the
communication uh for towards the
different microservices now like i said
that gateway is at risk of becoming too
large
it might know too much about the
different microservices and definitely
if you start using it from different
front-ends it might become too heavy and
it might turn into a monolith as well
not what you want in that case
if you have different front-ends
communicating with your microservices
that's when you start looking at the
back-end for front-end mechanism and the
back-end for front-ends sorry that's
what you see here so multiple com
multiple uh front-ends communicating
with the gateway
like i said not an ideal situation to be
in so what we are
typically proposing or typically doing
is having a specific
gateway for a specific frontend then you
have a specific backend for a front-end
that's what you see with the bff pattern
of the back-end for front-end pattern
where you have a front-end and a plain
mvc front-end that has a specific api
then you have maybe a mobile application
or xamarin and it has a specific
separate bff
for communicating with the microservices
but giving back responses which are
specific to your
mobile application and that's what you
should actually strive for in this
particular case
let's see if i still have time dylan is
it okay if i do another small demo
two minutes
yeah yeah
that that's that's definitely doable all
right let's quickly do that
so i have it already open here actually
you need to still need to open it here
this is a different solution
and then i can show you how that is set
up
so um the microservices haven't changed
nothing has changed there
uh but we have different front panes so
the actual front end so the regular one
was this one that is basically an mvc
application if we look at its
controllers let's look at the event
catalog controller
if you look here that uses
the event catalog service that's a
service a view service really that does
the communication with the backend if
you look at that you will see here down
here at the bottom for example here we
do a get category by id call
and that goes off to api slash events
that is a microservice so we're going
from the front end directly into the
microservices
typically not the ideal situation to be
in
a better solution is what is also
included here
uh is
using different bffs
as you can see you have gateway sitting
in between and that gateway will now be
the point of communication between my
front end and my microservices so if we
look here at so as you can see we have a
mobile bff and a
web bff the web bff
has a
controller for example for the catalog
and that does what we did what we did
before in the front end that now
contains the information to get all the
events and that will still do the call
to
um
the api call that's what you see over
here that will actually go out to the
microservice ins itself but the front
end will only know about this gateway so
all the logic of combining the on the
the responses of the different
microservices is now wrapped inside of
this gateway in this bff yeah and the
front ends well that is this separate uh
front end that's a canon
mvc application that now only knows if
you look at its event catalog controller
that now only knows
over here
and it only knows about the api bff
so it will only communicate to the
through the bff and it also increases of
course your security because you can put
your microservices between uh after the
firewall or the vpn and only this one
will need to talk with the microservices
in turn right so that's of course a much
easier way to secure the system as well
and with that
we are almost done
so let's wrap it up
i hope i've given you a bit of an
overview of how you can do mic services
it
first of all
as a big reminder it might not be the
solution for your particular problem it
can be a solution for larger
applications it's typically something
that tends to attempt to lend itself
better for larger applications but it's
not always a solution even for those
building it using asp.net core is of
course very well possible it's just apis
and those apis we need to consider how
we let them communicate and of course a
good way of doing that is a broker
which uh which we've seen uh using azure
service business image we have
asynchronous communication to let the
services communicate all right
i hope i've given you an overview that
that helps you a little bit i said i
have a five-hour course that goes a lot
deeper into setting up this sort of
application hope it was useful for you
thank you for skipping lunch to come and
listen to me i hope you enjoy the rest
of your day and the conference thank you
you